film claude oui benoît et l'actualité
aujourd'hui et ce soir en ce moment même
c'est la projection du film de leos
carax pola x le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est que ce film suscite beaucoup de
controverses et de polémiques
huit ans après les amants du pont neuf
qui ne fut pas franchement un succès léo
carax revient dans la lumière et vous
allez voir avec antoine cormery et
jean-louis mona
de lui on ne nous avait donné qu'une
photo floue et torturé de son film on ne
connaissait que le titre énigmatique
abréviation de celui d'un obscur romans
du xixème signe herman melville et puis
rompant un silence de huit ans le
réalisateur des amants du pont neuf est
venu à la rencontre de la presse
défendre son film sans lever pour autant
le voile sur cette si longue absence
le battant de huit ans pour faire ce
film j'ai attendu après une fois que je
voulu le faire un peu vert était
difficile de trouver de l'argent
h après les amants du pont neuf mais
c'est pas lui tant parlé d'un an à cause
de ça sinon moi j'étais ailleurs
ailleurs comme le héros tragique de pola
x aux côtés de catherine deneuve
guillaume depardieu y incarne un jeune
homme de bonne famille qui va quitter
une vie réglée et une blonde fiancée
après la rencontre d'une demi soeur dont
il ignorait l'existence
comment est-ce que tu me retrouver
je suis un livre avec vos pierres
il faut que je sois là
c'est impossible
congre folle mais 11
et c'est moi
c'est quelqu'un qui est très exigeant
sont vraiment le mot qui revient le plus
pour le qualifier même si des fois il
peut se tromper même si moi aussi que
nous serons prêts on arrive toujours à
s'entendre mais tournage sont beaucoup
plus agréables comprennent le français
c'est pas du tout on peut être maudit où
un cinéaste maudit quelqu'un qui
brimerait ses acteurs comme on voudrait
bien croire ce papa
pola x est une oeuvre sombre déroutant
qui laisse le spectateur sans espoir
leos carax lui nourrissent celui d'
effacer avec ce film ses précédents
échecs commerciaux
en sortant de l'ombre et en sacrifiant à
tous les mythes du festival de la
conférence de presse à la montée des
marches tout à l'heure les oscars at s'y
est employé aux côtés de ses acteurs
quoi qu'il lui en écouter